the jurogan experience
was that a satisfying one for you
because she was talking so much [ __ ]
before so
it's not even about like the [ __ ]
talking really it was just about like
how dare you guys compare her to me
that's what it was for me it was like
i had watched film of her and i had my
eyes set on her since i was 17
before i even had turn pro and i knew
then when i was 17
i could have beat her so now that i'm
you know i was like 22 or whatever
23 it's like what the hell do she do
that make you guys think she can beat me
like either i'm just a
terrible boxer or you guys just i don't
know think she's that good
i think sometimes when someone's
overwhelming
like you are the people try to pump up
challengers in in a way that they don't
even really believe
you know what i mean like they kind of
like i'm just gonna be honest i've had
to do that before
doing commentary like pretend like there
were certain dudes that i knew they were
going to fight
an accomplished champion and you knew
they were [ __ ] and so you have to kind
of play
their strong points but if you caught me
alone
and it was just you and me and it was
like no recording equipment
i would be like he's [ __ ] but you
can't
necessarily say that because he's
disrespectful to the opponent
and because you want to kind of make it
exciting yeah well i'm i'm a hype man
you know that's what i'm trying to do if
jon jones is fighting someone and i
think jon jones is going to slaughter
him
i'm going to put point out the guy's
strong points
i'll point out john strong points and
i'll point out the guy's strong points
and what he has to do and what he can do
where he excels
but sometimes they don't really believe
that [ __ ] and with you
i think the problem is they're always
trying to sell fights right
but it's it's hard to sell
when you you here's everybody else right
here's you
you're way you're you're you're so
advanced
in comparison like technique-wise
ability-wise
accomplishment-wise there's not a lot of
competition for you in boxing where
people are calling out for
other than occasionally people start
talking about layla
lee right occasionally that comes up
well she's
you know she's retired she's retired
she's probably
43 yeah and this is the thing i don't
respect about that right
i hate when somebody else try to take
somebody else shine somebody else's
attention
you know it's like she's you know nobody
was
trying to take her take her attention
when it was her time right
and that's why i didn't i didn't like
about hammer either when i went in a
world title fight
why are you jumping in the ring talking
about some you beat us both you say
congrats and get the [ __ ] out the ring
you know but she's getting there being
disrespectful and then layla gets upset
because
i become undisputed champion she's never
been undisputed
and people are comparing me to her and
she gets offended and when it was like
to me i thought it was a good comparison
because i feel like i box
way better than her and for them to be
saying that me and her
are equal or whatever she should have
been happy because of that because
they're giving her more
um more props on her skills which i feel
like she didn't really have that much
but you know whatever it was like i
never really had a problem with it and
then all of a sudden it's like
talking about she had knocked me out and
my record and this and that and i just
was like
hater that's all i kept thinking to
myself hate her
and i would have loved to fight her but
um at the end of the day
i'm an active fighter she's retired so
when people bring her up
like i don't want to have to keep saying
that i beat her because i think it's
evident but at the same time it's like
look it was she had her time
this is my time they don't even
correlate with each other
yeah that was last time she fought it
was like
2016 or something see if you could find
layla ali's
last professional 2016 you thinking real
no she's been retired like 13 12 years
has it been that long
yeah like i think her last fight was
2001. was it really
probably 2007. wow i was way off
east 2012 when i say what 2007.
i started boxing in 2006. i was like 11
years old and i started boxing so that
mean i was 12.
so basically she she retired when she
was like 30.
yeah which i took people all the time i
think that
that kind of eats at her you know she
retired at 29
30 in boxing when she was on top
you know and it was a lot of girls who
wanted to fight her she left without
fighting and wolf left without fighting
a girl named
latisha robinson it was a few girls who
she didn't fight
and wolf was the scariest in her day and
wolf is still scary to me now she's so
scary
remember she was training james kirkland
screaming at him in the corner she's a
terrifying trainer
she's an amazing trainer and terrifying
boxer
yeah she has like in my opinion the most
uh spectacular one punch knockout in the
history of women's boxing
i said history of boxing like that punch
there was like what the
i mean yeah i dreamed to get a knockout
like that like i thought my last fight
i'm like
that's my dream i want to knock this
girl out like and wolf knocked out mine
to war
that was my whole thing but it's like i
feel for later that she retired kind of
early
so everybody always compared whoever was
next up to her
but it was like still you're retired
yeah nobody
nobody is nobody fought because you're
retired have you ever worked with an
wolf
no i love to though yeah i would love to
see that yeah i think she needs to just
show me like
how to sleep a girl yeah because i would
hear this
boom man i'm talking about
this girl oh my goodness time on the
power
everything no and wolf was a monster and
it's really interesting like
when uh she was training because
you know her her work ethic you could
see it when she's training other
fighters
like she demanded like some serious work
from them and she had so much intensity
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience